what's up Wolfgang just gonna say right
off the bat there are some spoilers
coming up for Avengers infinity war so
if you have not seen it now's your
chance to turn away so at the end of
Avengers infinity war as most of you all
know vanos was successful at collecting
all of the Infinity stones for his
Infinity Gauntlet and we saw the
infamous Thanos snap from there we saw
some of our favorite heroes start to
disintegrate including most of the
guardians of the galaxy black panther
and a few of the avengers but did you
happen to catch who all survived if you
didn't notice all of the original
Avengers survived the snap could this
just be a mere coincidence no not at all
it is mostly known by now that Avengers
4 will be the end of an era and will be
the end from some of our favorite
Avengers Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige has been pretty talkative lately
he has spoken up about ant-man and the
wasp spider-man far from home Captain
Marvel and now he of course has spoken
up about this as well in a promotion for
ant-man and the wasp he spoke up and
said that he knows all too well that the
original Avengers are left and that it's
basically done on purpose in this
promotion he says I think for a film
series that is going on 10 years and is
gearing towards a conclusion with
Avengers 4 which you don't usually have
in these kind of movies you can sort of
do the math and realize it's the
original Avengers that are left so did
you pick up that part there about the
conclusion he pretty much stated that
this is the end for most of the original
Avengers we know that there is a solo
black widow movie being made and
Scarlett Johansson is still playing
Natasha Romanoff and with the major
success that thor ragnarok has gotten
and with the big plot that Thor got and
Avengers infinity war it's widely
believed that Chris Hemsworth will
continue to play the Mighty Thor but
what about the other original Avengers
well it seems like this is going to be
the end for Captain America Iron Man The
Hulk and Hawkeye so the Internet of
course has come up with a thousand
different ways that these characters
could either die or retire and pass down
the mantle or go back in time even I
think the most beloved theory right now
is around Captain America and that is
that at the end they'll defeat Thanos
and they'll have all the Infinity stones
and then he'll use the time stone to go
back in time and be with Peggy Carter
and that's where he'll spend the
remainder of his days of course there
are many other theories and speculations
that Captain America is just going to
die along with Ironman many people
believe that both of these characters
are going to die of course in big heroic
fashion saving the rest of the Avengers
and might I add the universe by
defeating Thanos and then Avengers four
will end with a funeral and ceremony
both to Iron Man and Captain America or
Tony Stark and Steve Rogers giving them
that respect they deserve but there is a
theory going around that I actually
particularly enjoy it's sort of a play
on the Illuminati from the comics this
theory states that the Avengers will
defeat Thanos obviously and will obtain
the Infinity Gauntlet and no Avengers
will die or if they do they will be
brought back to life at the end by the
power of the Infinity Gauntlet from
there the stones will be divided amongst
the Avengers Captain America as I said
using the time stone to go back and be
with Peggy Carter Scarlet Witch using
the reality stone to bring vision back
to life and possibly some House of M
stuff maybe coming here Bruce Banner
will use the mind stone to actually
separate himself from the Hulk Tony
Stark gets the power stone and
apparently just destroys it and then the
space stone will be used by Black Widow
and she will use it to go in outer space
adventures which we will see in the
Black Widow movie it's an interesting
theory and kind of nice to think about
because it kind of ends happily for all
of our beloved Avengers but to me it
would seem that Thor would be one of the
people that would take an infinity stone
after all he's one of the only people
who can really be strong enough to
harness the power of one but again these
are all just theories but it seems like
one thing is for certain this will be
the end of the original Avengers
obviously it's really sad to see this
come to an end but it's also really
exciting to see some of the new
characters that they're going to
introduce into the MCU starting with
Captain Marvel and again Marvel
president Kevin
[ __ ] all but confirmed this so it's
the end of the original Avengers let me
know how you all feel about this are you
heartbroken are you excited are you
angry hit me with all those feelings and
comments below
Hulk smash that like button if you
enjoyed this video and of course
subscribe to my channel to stay
up-to-date on Avengers for all things
Marvel DC and superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]